hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to reading your comments
number three
boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boop let's bring
old Horace and we're going to put some
boobs in the thumbnail [ __ ] but your
Foreman George Foreman that's not a real
grill that's a novelty grill contact
with this [ __ ] terrible it's too cute
tell me it's that's not a real group
George Foreman that's not a real grill
yours for me
that's not a real that's not a real
thrill is it BB grill
contact me some time and I'll get you a
real bro Gorge Foreman that's not a real
girl that's a novelty can you turn Super
Saiyan
mark I dare you to call up one of your
friends and with that explanation read
the most random comment you can find on
ear smiley face Oh
cuss type mode and every other mode is
frightening God has come to reap the
sinners alumina rod Oh confused
Japan has lost the war I didn't read
this one but I'm everything except the
anime even the kittens oh gosh the
kittens are scary mark what happened to
your glasses how come you don't wear
them anymore I think you need some
glasses yes markiplier could see this I
see everything
well that was dry and awkward just like
your mom
why did he dies hair pink WTF why did
you did not die your wife shut up what
is a douchebag I don't know a lot of
English well if you look at this image
here you'll see a perfect example of a
douchebag you can see by the distinctive
douchey features on his face that
obviously this guy is I'm sorry that was
stupid you're stupid
why have you tubers like jacksepticeye
and markiplier dyed their hair the same
color as their logo my logo is red
wait you seriously markiplier watch porn
at full volume I sure do i factored this
you mean this is it this mirrors mark
turning into Ricky Gervais Oh Ricky
Gervais all from London on Ricky Gervais
America which to watch your fat stupid
folk Roy Bell tea and biscuits crumpets
died it is full of Queen okay let me do
a British accent top o the morning to
you laddies own junk septic Oy food wins
the septic eye or tiny boxed in
well the septic eye is quite literally
by name a butthole so you know I present
to you a piece of clothing Marky you are
now a free elf you know long have to
make the videos I tell you to go now
mark are you going to America soon
let's go we'd the angle flip Greg lease
Nevel a girly tango Rackham got Ripley
Bentley Norodom mark I want you to give
me advice on YouTube on how to get sons
well first you got to take your powder
and then you gotta shove it all over the
floor
hey Mark tips on how to be a movie star
well as soon as hard to come one that
will let you know [ __ ] d-list
celebrity piece of [ __ ]
YouTube trash I knew mark was Asian
hello mark I'm having a stressful time
with school in the afternoon lessons
singing cello theatre school band and
more and all the other stuff that's
going on greetings from Israel and the
past few years weren't the best in my
life
but a few weeks ago I watched for the
first time one of your videos five
nights at freddys since then I'm never
leaving your side you make my day and
make me smile and I wanted to say a big
thank you and tell you that you're a
wonderful person when I grow up I want
to be like you well thank you so much I
mean I don't know if there was actually
a question in there but I just want to
say thank you so much for watching my
videos best of luck to all you're doing
in school and everything I really don't
have a job to make out of this comments
so just thanks for watching can I pop on
your face thanks so much for watching
reading your comments I hope you enjoyed
this one if you have comments that you
want me to read in the next video write
em in the description below we have a
lot of fun picking them out so even if
you don't think it'll make it in the
video still write a comment anyway we
probably will see it so thanks again
everybody so much for watching and
expect these every Monday from now on
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye